[Musique]
au même moment
greta tune berck prononcer ce célèbre
discours à l'onu
500 scientifiques climato sceptiques ont
envoyée au secrétaire général des
nations unies une lettre ni l'urgence
climatique
qui sont ces signataires bush l'a
enquêter et quelques nuances s'imposent
ma première question je suppose et
bouchra dès le départ jusqu'à quel point
ces gens là sont des scientifiques
véritablement donc ce ne sont pas tous
des scientifiques et parmi ceux qui sont
scientifiques ce ne sont pas tous des
climatologues
alors avec des collègues journalistes à
travers le monde on s'est penché pays
par pays sur l'identité des signataires
de la lettre
il y en a parmi ses 500 leur dise qu'ils
s'identifient comme des chercheurs en
climatologie
donc ceci 2% des signataires très faible
pourcentage exactement et parmi ceux là
il y en a certains qui sont
controversées par exemple rupture de
linden qui est un climatologue américain
dont les articles parfois ont été
retirés après publication des revues
scientifiques voilà parce qu'ils
contenaient des erreurs il y en a aussi
qui se sont octroyé le titre de
chercheur en climat mais contre quand on
creuse on se rend compte que ce n'est
pas le cas par exemple pas au micro et
qui était un des signataires canadien
qui lui est assignée comme chercheur
indépendant en climat mais on le
contacte et on lui a posé la question et
il s'avère qu'il n'a pas de formation
scientifique il est plutôt professeur
d'anglais ya beaucoup de géologues donc
un sur cinq dessinateurs et géologue met
donc ce ne sont pas des experts du
climat sont plutôt des experts des de la
terre on retrouve aussi un psychanalyste
un architecte un pilote d'avion donc des
gens qui ne sont pas du tout limmat
relègue donc chaude qui mentionnait pas
malgré qu'ils étaient
en bout de ligne prof d'anglais je
comprends bien canadienne d'origine
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres des
canadiens parmi ses 500 6 personnes 1
individu scientifique ou non oui donc 17
canadiens ont signé la lettre notamment
un long qui revient souvent dans les
médias au québec reynald du berger et un
géologue un sismologue donc on experts
des tremblements de terre il ya aussi
jack frost qui était professeur de
philosophie et on retrouve notamment un
ingénieur que travaillé longtemps dans
le domaine des sables bitumineux
cette lettre ne l est chapeauté par une
organisation qui s'appelle cours intel
qui a été fondée par un néerlandais de
cybercartes il lui pour fonder cet
organisme là il a reçu un demi million
d'euros d'un milliardaire
climato-sceptiques néerlandais nexans
man plusieurs os x sont affiliés au rod
land institute qui lui est financé en
grande partie par la pétrolière exxon
mobil et si on parle du fond des choses
sur ce que ces personnes avancent comme
argument
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire là dessus leur
argument ils sont contredits par la
science par exemple ils disent que
l'influencé humaine elle n'est pas
significative que le climat toujours
changer mais ce qu'on constate c'est que
oui le climat changé depuis toujours
mais qu'il s'accélère de façon
significative avec une influence humaine
et disent également que le co2 c'est pas
de la pollution mais c'est quelque chose
qui est utilisé par les plantes
soit c'est un argument qui avait été
repris par maxime b le co2 est un gaz
qui existent d'un gars que j'aime est
actuellement en vous parlant c'est un
gars que les plantes utilisées comme
nourriture
effectivement le co2 ce n'est pas un
polluant mais c'est un agent de
réchauffement climatique oui c'est
utilisé par les plantes mais ça a un
effet sur le réchauffement climatique et
des aussi que pas de lien entre le
réchauffement climatique et les
catastrophes naturelles
et c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas lier
chaque catastrophe naturelle au
réchauffement climatique mais on
constate et saucier documenté que le
niveau de la mer augmente avec le
réchauffement de la planète et que ça ça
crée des inondations
autre chose est certaine bouchra quand
on voit apparaître ce genre d'initiative
de l'espace médiatique ça ajoute à la
confusion ambiante
oui parce que ça donne l'impression au
grand public qu'il ya débat au sein des
experts anthony m'a alors qu'en fait il
y à vraiment consensus au sein des
experts en climat sur les réchauffements
climatiques et sur l'influencé humaine à
voilà
quand vous voyez un titre comme ça parce
que ce genre de chose qui peut vous être
lancée sur votre opinion dans le fond
regardez lui dans un article comme ça je
pense moi tu vois par exemple 170 qu on
va se demander si l'échangé de figues là
sont reconnus ou pas ça me fatigue de
vous rendre 500 scientifiques ce qui ce
qu'ils ont écrit
d'où ils viennent les scientifiques
c'est ce que même le comité scientifique
est divisée de la publicité quand même
de facebook vous accorder de
l'importance aux scientifiques qui
disent il faut pas aller si vite que ça
je me suis trompé
c'est aux états et que faut pas créer
une psychose damas avec ça ce qui me
semble que les missions sont en train de
faire actuellement
si on veut vraiment se sentir et ci
dessus on va faire plus de recherches
pour voir plusieurs sur différentes
d'après vous il ya un consensus
scientifique oui je pense qu'il ya un
consensus scientifique je pense qu'à ma
propre consensus scientifique à ce sujet
là parce qu'il y en a qui sont beaucoup
plus modérés
vous le voyez les avis sont parfois
partagés sur la simple question du
consensus scientifique cette lettre
signée ne fait qu'ajouter à la confusion
précisément ce que déplore michel g brac
professeur émérite de luca
dans un premier temps dites moi comment
vous avez réagi en voyant cette
publication cette lettre bah c'est pas
nouveau c'est pas nouveau ça fait des
années qu'on voit des groupes de petits
scientifiques qui font des lettres de ce
type là qui parfois même sont des études
pour essayer de démontrer que le
consensus qu'on actuellement sur le
changement climatique et ce qui est
écrit là dedans ce sont des opinions sur
une situation qu'a pas été analysés la
deuxième chose aussi qu'on peut regarder
ces les auteurs évidemment c'est entier
regarde maintenant il ya des gens qui
ont jamais travaillé sur les choses au
clair
je comprends qu'ils peuvent avoir une
opinion changement climatique comme vous
pouvez en avoir mais n'ayant pas
travaillé sur la réalité physique
question mathématique on est dans le
domaine du commentaire éditorial donc
sans avoir vraiment de réalité et puis
dans cette liste de gens on voit qu'il
ya aussi des gens qui ont des intérêts
des maisons qui par exemple travaille
avec l'industrie et parfois des
industries qui émettent des gaz à effet
de serre évidemment c'est très difficile
pour ces gens-là d'admettre qu'ils sont
en fait complice peut faire la
comparaison avec ce qui s'est passé dans
le code est fumeur il ya eu pendant
longtemps des gens qui du géant vous
savez le fumer ça tue pas peut-être
comme c'est bon pour la santé respirer y
avait un consensus mais il ya des gens
qui se mêlent doute qu'ils étaient
financés par par des puissances
financières dont c'est la même chose
intéresse quasi on peut se poser des
questions effectivement sur le fait
qu'il ya des gens qui ont intérêt à ne
pas bouleverser l'économie comme
effectivement arrêter les hydrocarbures
dans le fonctionnement de la société
c'est une révolution absolument majeure
et donc qu'il y aura comme dans toutes
les révolutions des gagnants et des
perdants
comment il se fait que autun de
géologues qui font partie de ce clan des
sept communautés des climato sceptiques
à l'arrêt la raison est assez simple
pour un géologue la planète c'est la
terre et la planète effectivement depuis
4 milliards d'années
ed vraie révolution extraordinaire
penser qu'ici il y avait deux kilomètres
de glace à montréal il ya deux mille ans
donc les jeunes qu'ils ont tendance à
voir un certain recul par rapport à
l'évolution
planet l'échelle de temps cdh les
millions d'années ce qui se passait mais
celle de 10 ans ou 30 ans c'est un
détail pour les géologues pour certains
géologues
donc c'est pour ça que c'est les jeux
ont souvent ce regard en disant mais
c'est pas grave pour la planète elle va
continuer à tourner
rip pour les hawks dessus c'est un peu
différent est-ce qu'on devrait quand
même se méfier de cette notion de
consensus scientifique d'abord qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un consensus scientifique
c'est quoi c'est pas 51 % 49 mon sens on
n'est pas dans des élections
démocratiques au desk un conseil
scientifique c'est 90 95 % du smic qui
sont d'accord avec les faits et leur
interprétation
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose à faire de
plus chez les scientifiques
scientifiques peuvent faire deux choses
d'abord ils peuvent apprendre à
communiquer ça suffit comme il peut la
deuxième chose qui doivent se servir de
leur meilleur allié leurs meilleurs
alliés ces gens là liste ne tue pas ça
pour vous là je dis simplement que si
j'en ai se comprenait comment se fait la
science eh bien il pourrait avoir une
manière de transmettre la science de
manière plus efficace et c'est pas le
cas c'est pas le cas car on sait bien
qu'on aime des controverses ya du pognon
politique
on adore mettre d'extrême gauche
accueille d'extrême droite ou des
éléments de ce type là où à qui va être
sceptique avec avec un scientifique de
pointe
évidemment on voit deux opinions deux
côtés de la table et on dit à la barre
je choisisse entre les deux ans près de
choix n'y a pas deux opinions
il ya un consensus scientifique fort et
il ya un dissident qui n'a pas
d'arguments solides à bord donc pense
que c'est la honte
[Musique]